what is a mirror speaking in strictly
literal terms it's a reflective pane of
glass that we use to check our hair or
the clothes we've decided to wear
seriously how did you match that shirt
with those pants but think about it
another way what is a mirror for well
it's for showing us ourselves allowing
us to see what everybody else around us
does when they look in our direction in
that way you could say that a mirror is
honest a mirror doesn't lie but that
doesn't mean they can't hold secrets
behind that looking glass also known by
the alternate name of the red sea object
scp-093 is not a mirror itself it's
actually a red disc that has been carved
from cinnabar cinnabar for anyone not
already aware is a toxic ore of mercury
that has been crafted into jewelry and
ornaments in many parts of the world
over the centuries thanks to its
ruby-like red coloration the scp-093
disc itself is only around 7.62
centimeters in diameter fitting
comfortably in most average sized palms
all around the object are a number of
symbols carved into its surface strange
circular engravings of unknown origin
the color of the redstone disc will also
apparently change based on whatever
regrets are being carried by the person
who holds it there seems to be some link
between color changes and the mental
state or level of knowledge possessed by
the subject to put it in much simpler
terms think of
scp-093's color like one of those
novelty mood rings you see in gift shops
that change to different hues supposedly
to match a person's mood although in
actuality it's normally changed by their
body heat the same cannot be said of the
red sea object it is stunningly accurate
in peering into your soul and diagnosing
the darkness within if ever you come
into contact with this baby you might
even discover that it knows you better
than you so a weird stone disc doesn't
sound all that impressive does it and
what does that have to do with mirrors
well scp-093 happens to have a certain
attachment to mirrors and we mean that
very very literally if the red sea
object is ever not in front of a mirror
or not being held by someone it will
speed towards the closest reflective
surface as it rolls its way in the
direction of the nearest mirror or
mirror-like surface
scp-093 is capable of building up
phenomenal speeds although curiously it
never appears to cause any impact damage
when it finally arrives neither to
itself nor the mirror it latches onto
which brings us to the next inevitable
question what happens when scp-093 is
placed on or attaches itself to a mirror
does it create a copy of the person who
last touched it a clone that reflects
all the darkest parts of someone's
personality maybe it can allow the
holder of scp-093 to themselves become
like a mirror bending light away from
their body in order to become
functionally invisible well it's
actually neither of these the truth is
far more strange and existential during
extensive testing the scp foundation
investigated the potential anomalous
uses for scp-093
paying especially close attention to how
the red sea object interacted with
mirrors after a number of unsuccessful
tests they finally learned what happens
when someone places the disk onto a
mirror they move into the mirror any
mirror that scp-093 is placed against or
otherwise attaches itself to is
transformed into a portal of anomalous
origin and destination naturally the
first instinct of the foundation
personnel examining this artifact is to
send through an expedition to explore
the other side of this newly formed
mirror portal so that's what they did
they gathered up a member of d-class the
imprisoned criminals that the foundation
uses as expendable subjects for
dangerous tests the subject was given
water ready to eat meals a flashlight a
gun and a concealed knife the latter of
which the d-class was not made aware of
the first subject despite having a past
of murder and attempted suicide seemed
to regret his actions and willingly
agreed to cooperate with testing and as
a result
scp-093 emitted a blue glow that also
tinted the view in the mirror perhaps on
the other side he expected to meet his
end and expected it as a righteous
punishment for his life of sin stepping
through the mirror to the other side of
the looking glass the d-class found
himself in an empty field not another
person or even a single tree in sight
traversing forwards he quickly came
across a section of grass that was
barren wilted and dying in the center of
which was a hole climbing in as per
foundation instructions the man found
only dirt for about a hundred meters but
then something strange happened the dirt
around him gradually gave way to a
concrete enclosure that the man remarked
stank of something awful the room was
lit by a series of ceiling light
fixtures some of which were already
broken three doors were positioned on
either side of the enclosure with an
extra door at the far end blocked by
some fallen metal shelving the existence
of a place like this seemed to imply
that someone was present beyond the
portal or at least they had been this
ancient underground bunker lost to time
seemed to have traces that people had
once lived there in one of the adjacent
rooms the ceiling seemed to be coated in
a smelly brown sludge but it was in here
that the d-class discovered a makeshift
cot wooden crates containing foodstuffs
and empty water bottles and a book lying
next to the cot when he attempted to
approach the book he was assaulted by a
screeching noise like grinding metal the
door was beginning to close as the
d-class dashed out the body cam he'd
been fitted with seemed to pick up a
figure standing at the end of the
corridor where the seventh door was it
opened the door from behind just to
crack looked in and silently shut it
once more finding only crumpled
newspapers and food rations the
foundation ordered the intrepid d-class
to return to the mirror suddenly
something tugged at the lifeline secured
around his waist something was pulling
him up out of the tunnel while trying to
get back to the mirror the d-class
witnessed a group of 37 figures all of
them faceless with no discernible
features to speak of in his escape he
opened fire with a gun he'd been issued
but not of the crowd had something
bigger a massive humanoid creature
around 50 times bigger than an average
person was crawling around on the ground
like the other figures this giant was
without a face pulling itself towards
the mirror as the d-class was reeled
back through the mirror by a cable and
pulley after their first glimpse into
the world within scp-093
naturally the foundation was curious to
learn more the next test revealed more
about this other reality for one that
the red sea object seemed to choose its
locations based on the personal history
of whoever was traveling through a
mirror this time it was a female d-class
who had killed two children while
stealing a car she arrived at a
farmhouse which had a bunker of its own
like the first test much like then there
were definite signs that someone had
inhabited the bunker before her arrival
the most telling were the three
skeletons an empty revolver it seemed
that everyone in this world lived in
bunkers at some point possibly to hide
from the various faceless creatures that
roamed the landscape additionally any
remnants of a civilization that were
uncovered seemed to fit the aesthetic of
the 1950s however this civilization also
seemed to have technology compared to
that found in the 21st century the
d-class discovered a laptop the casing
of which also seemed to resemble a 50s
style booting the machine up revealed
the final moments of its operating
system something called faithful os
instances of the same operating system
seemed to crop up everywhere the more
the foundation sent expeditions through
the mirrors the world that scp-093 had
offered access to seem to be brimming
with advanced technology far more
impressive inventions than anything that
exists in our world not just computers
either but this world even had
functional self-driving cars suck on
that elon musk and yet even with all
that advancement they were still stuck
in the 50s 1953 to be exact as one
expedition discovered that this was the
last recorded year of this world but
something had clearly occurred here some
sort of devastating event that had wiped
out almost all of humanity and driven
the survivors into underground bunkers
where they eventually perished but what
the sudden arrival of those faceless
creatures was it more to do with that
strange viscous brown sludge that seemed
to be cropping up all over the place
this world seemed to be abundant with
religious imagery even down to the
naming of faithful os symbols of hands
clasped together in prayer and other
iconography linked to christianity could
be found everywhere from the outer sides
of buildings to the computers and
folders found when the foundation
expeditions delve deeper into the cities
and offices in one they discovered a
waiting area assumed to be connected to
a doctor's office which provided more
clues as to just what had happened here
examining the contents of the
receptionist's computer in this office
revealed that the doctors of this world
were deeply ingrained in theology and
were responsible for treating their
patients for a number of strange
symptoms one entry described a woman
citizen jennifer mazurka who seemingly
suffered a lapse of the heart this
apparent condition caused her to sin
committing adultery before she was
admitted into the lords in our hands for
cleansing of mind and body it appeared
that this world took religion to an
extreme employing doctors to cure
sinners of their trespasses through the
use of something referred to as the
lord's tears that brown fluid splattered
all over this mirror world this
substance as the foundation soon learned
was harvested from the giant faceless
creatures that roamed freely around this
place but the question still remained
why the answers were uncovered in
another expedition this time by a
foundation service technician who was
able to make scp-093 turn a bright red
color when he affixed it to a mirror he
was transported to a room with a
rotating pillar with beams of light that
shone upon other copies of scp-093
various copies of the mirror portal
system seem to be leading to other
mysterious worlds as if looking back
behind the curtain the technician found
an adjacent room filled with computer
equipment monitoring these other worlds
and categorizing them as either clean
unclean or lost so what do we have where
does all this leave us besides
scratching our heads clearly some sort
of cataclysmic disaster occurred in one
of these mirror worlds it had once been
a place where technology had boomed in
the 1950s but that was also steeped in
religious beliefs to the extent where
sinners were treated with a strange
substance extracted from those faceless
creatures it seems as if some time ago a
godlike being known only as him arrived
in one of these worlds and this served
as the catalyst for such an advancement
in technology however he had also deemed
this world to be unclean and full of sin
mandating a purge of all sinners in
order to cleanse the world as a result a
holy war took place to determine who was
worthy of salvation a deeply religious
society formed around the arrival of him
and their primary weapon against the
sinners was this brown liquid his holy
tears and those monsters prowling around
one part of the unclean their sins given
form except none of that was true there
was never a war no fight between
holiness and cleanliness the truth was
this being this eldritch abomination had
arrived to conquer using the discs like
scp-093 he traveled to that world fed
them lies and turned the people into his
followers becoming the master of their
world and eventually its destroyer
ultimately
scp-093 is a warning a look at what
happens when a being like this takes
over the broken dead world that the red
sea object transports us to is a legacy
of his destruction a false god preying
on humanity and their beliefs like a
theological predator then when his work
is done he moves on to find a new world
to conquer we can only hope that his
gaze never rests upon ours or that what
the red sea object knows of our many
sins will be the least of our problems
now go check out
scp-2317 the devourer of worlds a door
to another world and
scp-001 the black moon for more monsters
we definitely don't want to encounter in
our dimension